there are multiple watch parties of
course going on for the big game
tomorrow once again downtown Henderson's
Water Street Plaza is holding a big
event and expecting a pretty big turnout
well Candace Charles is already live
there now you've got your seat already
set up camp out smart move give us the
details Candace
I'd stand them
especially that stent the thing is going
nice all over the place here as I get
ready for their watch party tomorrow
we're hoping it's the last game we're
hoping it's a good one that I've Ron
shared here with me thank you so much
for joining us today tell us a little
bit people can expect out here I hear
there's going to be a DJ there will be a
DJ live DJ it's going to be a lot of fun
uh we've got some giveaways dance
contests family friendly parents can
hang out here watch the kids jungle gyms
I mean food vendors beverages everything
everything and of course that big
Jumbotron right there how big is that
thing that is 42 feet wide you are not
going to find a bigger TV anywhere
around here so uh yeah get get out here
and watch the game tomorrow and we'll
we'll get a win and clinch the cup
speaking of getting a win and now people
are starting to think about what's going
to happen after that win knock on wood
right what do you guys have planned out
here can you tell me a little bit run a
little sneak peek well Candace since you
and I are friends and it's just you and
I talking nobody else is listening
watching so yeah
um I can't tell you anything right now
oh so close so close thank you Ron for
joining us this morning we appreciate
you know the city of Henderson we've
always got fun stuff for our residents
so we're uh we're talking about some
things and uh you know it'll be good
it'll be a good party that's why I like
to hear Ron thank you we appreciate you
joining us this morning of course all
the details about tomorrow's watch party
will be on our website newsnow.com
remember to arrive early this street
here will be blocked off parking will be
available throughout the parking garage
again get here early people start
showing up around two o'clock guys so
you want to get your seat you might want
to get here a little bit early but for
now live from Wall Street Plaza I'm
Candace Charles 8 news now and just take
the day off now and Wednesday because
you'll be celebrating so just plan now
cross fingers Candace CrossFit thanks
Candace